alright guys bangbang I've got Andrew
here with me super excited to do this so
what they start doing it yeah thanks so
much for having me all right let's start
with with your background you've covered
it in a number of other podcast maybe
just give us kind of the two minutes for
those that don't know you or tiny I'm
kind of what you did in the past and
what tiny is yeah so I'm kind of a
accidental entrepreneur and then
accidental investor so I started a
design agency about 15 years ago and I
realized that if I pretended to be an
agency instead of what I really was
which is some shmo kid in his parents
basement
I could probably charge more and look a
little more legit and so I came up with
the name metal AB and I started calling
founders of startups back in 2006 and to
my surprise I ended up landing a whole
bunch of work and so um that ended up
growing like crazy I got a network in
Silicon Valley I started working with
companies and ended up working with
companies like slack and coinbase and
Shopify and all sorts of amazing
businesses early on and because I was
based in Canada you know I had pretty
good margins and usually agencies don't
and so suddenly I'd look at my bank
account and I see cash piling up and I
didn't really know what to do with it
and so initially I looked at like
Basecamp and all these amazing SAS
businesses they're getting built and I
went well I want to do that I want to
make money while I sleep and I want
recurring revenue and so I built a
couple SAS software businesses and got
hooked on this idea of recurring revenue
and you know waking up every morning and
having made money overnight and I kept
doing that and so I built some software
businesses and then I ended up
partnering with Shopify and being their
first major partner in their theme store
and app store and ended up building I
think the largest or the one largest
partner businesses in that ecosystem and
so I just kept starting more and more
businesses all sorts of dumb stuff that
failed and that
we don't need to talk about but by about
2013 I owned about five businesses they
were all profitable and cash flowing and
growing but I hadn't really scaled out
my executive team I was still running
all of them as CEO and it was a
nightmare I'd wake up every day and I'd
have five companies to think about and I
think at that point I had over a hundred
employees and I really wasn't very happy
even though I was making more money than
I ever thought I would and so I went to
a mentor of mine and I said look I am
NOT enjoying this very much what should
I do and he said look why don't you sell
one of the businesses and so I ended up
selling the Shopify partner business and
suddenly it had a balance sheet I had
money in the bank and I realized that I
couldn't just keep starting businesses
and then I probably had to figure out
this whole investing thing and to me
like stocks for these boring weird
things in the newspaper with charts and
wasn't really something I was that
interested in but I picked up a book
about Warren Buffett and when I read
about Buffett I was like holy crap this
is mind-blowing you know he's the fourth
wealthiest man in the world and yet he
and he owns like 70 companies and yet he
just sits on his butt reading all day
and doesn't have a calendar and I wow if
he can do it I'm sure I can probably
copycat that that sounds pretty cool and
so I learned everything I could about
Berkshire Hathaway and I decided I
wanted to build the Berkshire Hathaway
of tech and so I started putting that
money to work and I started buying tech
businesses and usually they were founder
led founders were you know eight 10
years in and they're a little exhausted
they were kind of tapped out wanted to
move on and do something else and they
didn't want to sell the private equity
because private equity was gonna flip
their business and we're in their
culture and take the thing that they'd
built and probably mess with it and so
we would do these super quick simple
deals and promise to hold the business
for a long term keep the culture intact
and not mess with it and because I was a
founder and I had been through
conversations with private equity we
knew all the things we could do to make
it more interesting and so I've been
doing that for about seven years now
we're up to about twenty-five businesses
that's pretty
cool I mean I get to wake up every day
and really focus my energy on acquiring
you know new businesses and doing deals
and then just overseeing our portfolio
of businesses and working with our CEOs
but I actually don't have a job like
day-to-day I don't have any one thing I
have to do and I get to be very broad
and kind of play with lots of
interesting businesses and problems so
it's awesome and I get to do it all from
Victoria Canada in the middle of nowhere
where I can dress like a Schmo and
nobody knows what I do so that's nice so
obviously there's a lot of people who
look at what you've built and they're
one fascinated by it but two they want
to understand kind of the operational
details and what I mean by that is I
really look at it as two components one
is how you spend your time every day and
you alluded to some of that but we can
go deeper on that in a second the second
thing is when you go in and you buy
these companies how much integration is
happening with kind of the family of
companies you already own and then what
does that kind of first 90 days post
acquisition look like and I'm assuming
that once you get up to 20 25 companies
you guys have some sort of process or
structure in place that that kind of
helps facilitate that make it as
seamless as possible but maybe talk a
little bit about what that transition
and integration looks like so I mean our
goal is that when we buy a business the
day after the deal closes the employees
wake up and they don't even know or care
that there's literally no difference
whatsoever and you know typically it's a
founder who wants to sell and usually
not always but usually the founder wants
to transition out and so what we
typically do is for a month or two
beforehand we're kind of identifying the
opportunities we're learning the
business and how it works and stuff and
then we're identifying a new leader to
come in and transition in a CEO and so
you know that's the big thing but the
commitment is that the culture of the
business doesn't change we're not going
to radically change anything day-to-day
for the employees and really just try
and kind of grow sustainably and
organically the biggest thing that
changes for our businesses is we become
the bank so we basically say like okay
you have
a million box of working capital in your
bank account and if you have to we're
gonna take that extra million bucks and
it's going to go up to head office and
get utilized in another acquisition or
something unless there's some reason to
keep the money there but other than that
all the businesses run fully
independently we don't force any kind of
integration any kind of group
conversation every business if it was to
separate from taani tomorrow would be
able to operate fully so they have their
own accounting team their own CFO if
they're big enough all their own you
know hiring and stuff we don't synergize
at all and that's a learning from
Berkshire it's you know the
decentralized model works really well
for them because CEOs want to work for
them and they're not slamming these
businesses together unnecessarily I
think if you look at like there are
synergized conglomerates that works but
for the most part the world is littered
with partner corpses right yeah and so
how do you have those conversations with
the management teams right so you give
the example of anything over a million
dollars and operating capital is kind of
getting pulled up to the parent company
is that something that you guys are
unilaterally deciding and kind of
running some math on is that a shared
conversation but you guys have the final
say like just talk to me a little bit
about that relationship for what I would
consider some of the more sensitive
conversations with the actual teams that
are operating the business on a day to
day basis I mean generally it's based on
historical working capital so if the
businesses you know only needs two
months of operating runway at any given
time and that covers any fluctuations in
revenue River that's what we'll do and
let's say the CEO comes to us and they
say look if I spend a million dollars on
customer acquisition or advertising or
something we're gonna make way more
money in three months we'll obviously
keep the money and keep compounding and
it's more for capital that just can't be
utilized by the business we send it back
up to head office and we basically say
look we're your bank we're gonna take
care of you you need money in 24 hours
we're gonna inject it you want to do an
acquisition we're gonna inject it so in
a lot of ways it's really nice because
the management team doesn't have to
think of
their runway as much and they know that
they have a partner who can always you
know do whatever they need to do and
grow them as big as they need to grow
yeah that's awesome
and then you mentioned that a lot of
times when you buy these companies the
founders are looking to go do something
else either they've been out at a long
time or they have other interest how do
you think about identifying and
recruiting new leadership talent right
so the actual CEOs are to come in and
kind of replace those founders obviously
a lot of companies the culture is set by
the founder the vision is set by the
founder and so that would be in many
people's eyes kind of a risk if they're
gonna walk out the door you know and
even if it's on good terms how do you
kind of think through the risks
associated with replacing them right
after an acquisition or during an
acquisition and then how do you find
that talent yeah I mean the way we find
them is generally through our existing
CEOs so that's our best source we
basically go to our existing CEOs and
say hey we're about to buy a business
this is what it looks like and who's the
smartest person you know in this space
and then from there we're looking for
people who have done it before like I
always say if you're gonna build a deck
in your backyard you're gonna hire a red
cell carpenter you're gonna I'm not
gonna hire some kid from down the street
and so we are really looking for people
who have already done it and they've
done it bigger so if we're buying a
business that has 30 million of revenue
I'm actually looking for the person
who's run a 60 million dollar business
and scaled it in terms of the risk you
know I think hiring a new CEO is brain
surgery right and you don't want to do
it too many times otherwise you know the
patient will not do well so we're very
cautious about who's going to be aligned
cult
for example like when we bought dribble
it was like I think it was maybe like a
six or seven person team and everyone
there had this culture of like
incredible product and design and you
know really giving a damn about that
kind of stuff we knew that there was
opportunities to grow the business but
we also needed somebody who understood
the unique culture so if we brought in
some douchey growth marketer yeah he
probably could have pulled a bunch of
levers and grown at a bunch but what we
would have ruined the culture and so
when we recruited for that business we
recruited this guy's a can disco who'd
run creative market which is a very
similar business for the big design
community and we're very cautious about
making sure that we were aligned on the
goals and the high level and that he
understood the culture and that we could
protect the things that made it the
business special but then remove some of
the restraints that would allow it to
grow more quickly and give them extra
resources got it and I'm assuming just
given how many times you guys have done
it there's got to be a mistake that
you've made at some point just the law
of numbers don't mention who it is or
what company but maybe give us just some
kind of details on how you evaluated hey
look this may not have been the right
hire and then how you dealt with that
situation given there a bit of
transaction of changing hands then you
bring in a new CEO and and kind of
dealing with repercussions of just
naturally you're gonna get not all well
there's really three buckets there's
mental health right as a challenge of
just you know people suffer from burnout
or something like that and then there's
skill set so putting the wrong person
into the wrong seat and then you know
the third is just bad people right
people who are dishonest or are you know
sociopathic or whatever and we've been
really really lucky I mean we've hired
probably 15 plus senior leaders and GM's
and all that kind of stuff and the
lion's share of them have been
phenomenal there was one person that we
hired where they were not truthful on
their their claims about prior success
and they ended up being you know very
dishonest and we had to part ways with
them
that's one exception where I look at it
and go there's somebody who's actually a
bad actor every every other kind of
challenging hire has been more that we
shuffled someone who is maybe two
operational into a leadership role where
they had to be a strategic and creative
and it just wasn't the right fit and we
had to make a change there oh and then
you know we've had a few situations
where people get a little burnt out and
then you take time off for transition
out or whatever but we've been very
lucky for the most part so for you
personally you obviously have the
benefit the curse of spending your time
as you see fit and for people who have
done that before they know that it's
really rewarding but also you can waste
a bunch of time and not be super
productive as well so how do you think
about breaking down your time on a day
to day basis and any sort of
productivity hacks or things that you do
to kind of ensure that you're making
progress with that freedom that you have
yeah I mean I'm I'm like laser focused
on a problem for a very short period of
time I burn bright but for like you know
15 days right so I'm very very good at
starting right so I can take an idea
from zero to one and I very aggressively
push it forward and I'm incredibly
impatient like if I come up with a
business idea I want action on it within
24 hours I'm buying a domain I'm
designing a site I'm putting together a
team but after about 15 to 20 days I'm
on to the next thing
and so I used to beat myself up when I
was running companies I was a horrible
CEO in many ways because I'd start an
initiative and then I'd lose focus and
I'd move on to the next thing and so
what I've realized about myself is
instead of whipping myself and trying to
become a CEO that I'm not I'm much
better suited to having hyper focus when
we have a critical problem like if one
of our CEOs calls me up I can get on the
phone and I can help them figure out a
problem or if we're starting a new
initiative I can push that forward but I
need to be kind of an inch deep and a
mile wide and so I love having 25
different businesses with interesting
problems where I can jump in and help
solve them but at the end of the day I'm
not responsible for follow-through and
execution and day-to-day details and so
I need to have
incredible group of CEOs and executors
to help me achieve those things yeah and
I saw speaking of kind of the problems
and that velocity of action if you will
I saw you tweeting one time about the
furniture business that you guys started
right you had a friend who basically
created some pretty cool furniture and
it sounds like you guys had a meeting or
some sort of meal together and you said
hey you should do this at scale and it
was like within weeks there was a
business started and out and selling
maybe one tell us some of the details in
there and then - that can lead us into
talking about kind of this no code
movement and how that empowers some of
that speed to actually launching things
yes so I've really moved away from
starting businesses I used to be the guy
who whatever I'd become interested in
I'd started business so if I got into DJ
I actually diced a DJ and I started an
online DJ school like if I got into
gardening I'd started gardening because
that's whatever it is I love that and I
really over the last seven years since I
started buying businesses I realized
that I'm a lot better at buying
something that's already good and making
it even better versus starting something
from zero and then having to scale it up
I get frustrated I want to get I want to
skip ahead to your five or whatever and
so I really have tried my best to not
starting new businesses and this year I
started a couple mostly kind of by
accident right so the tenth the one
you're thinking of was a furniture
business I was playing tennis with this
guy who's a furniture designer he showed
me what he was doing he wasn't selling
it online I was just like oh my god we
should totally do this and because I own
you know a couple agencies I was able to
just the email send one email and say
hey let's do a brand and the Shopify
site and let's build this and before I
knew it we had an accidental business
that I was a partner in so that's not
really my mo it's not really my goal but
occasionally I will accidentally start
businesses here and there but I try not
to the other the other business that I
started this year was a podcasting
business called super cast and that was
one where we were helping a podcaster
friend build some software to help him
monetize his podcast and we ended up
kind of building the software and going
hey
more people should use this and this is
a huge opportunity so we ended up
raising money for it but again like it's
not my goal to start businesses I want
to be buying businesses yeah and it
feels like if we were talking about
doing this 10 or 15 years ago that would
be a really arduous process to actually
get the business started get it launched
and start testing whether it works or
not today with the no code kind of
movement a lot of the businesses that
are getting created there that's much
easier and I know you've talked a little
bit about the no code stuff before but
maybe kind of just give us an your
perspective on kind of where we are
today and how you see that specific
vertical developing over the next couple
of years yeah so I mean my I said
earlier I was I'm super high paced I
love seeing stuff happen quickly and so
I used to get really frustrated I'm
originally a designer I would design
something in Photoshop and I'd hand it
off to a front-end developer to do it in
HTML or start building a web app or
whatever and I get so frustrated because
it would always take a day or two to do
it and I didn't know enough I didn't
know JavaScript I couldn't get in there
and tweak it and stuff and so when I
started using web flow about four or
five years ago I was like holy crap this
is amazing I don't have to worry about
hosting or coding I can just myself
design something and build it and so I
ended up building the original tiny
Capitol website and it was such an
awesome experience because I had the
idea and executed it within 24 hours and
so you know no code since then is
obviously grown a lot that web flow is
just for websites but this idea that
with very very simple tools you can
basically clone something like Airbnb or
you could build a you know a complex
form or something like that where you're
piecing together all these different
services and basically making a web app
without coding I think is very powerful
because you can test an idea you can
come up with an idea for an MVP and you
can see if you can get revenue and
validate the idea before you go out and
raise money and hire a whole bunch of
people and go through that and so it
shortens the cycle to get to
product market fit and to get to a point
where you have a basic MVP and I don't
think that you know we're not going to
be running Airbnb should not be running
on no code platforms right like it's not
about that it's about creating the
really simple version of it it's like if
you look at Axios Axios has all these
newsletters they could have and they
probably do use MailChimp or Aweber or
something like that to start but then as
they get bigger yeah maybe they build
their own custom code but it enables
people to get started and move quickly
and so you know you see that same effect
the Squarespace effect of your
restaurant you don't need a web
developer I think the same thing is
going to happen with Web Apps and pretty
soon mobile apps and I'm super excited
about that from just the idea of testing
MVPs what I'm really interested in is
the idea of you know right now it's not
worth anyone owning a business that
requires developers and coding that does
say a hundred or two hundred thousand
dollars a year simply because there's no
way to employ the people you need and
still make a profit with no code I think
there's a potential to have a two
hundred thousand dollar a year business
that is actually profitable and makes
someone a hundred thousand and well I'm
not interested in that scale I think
it's gonna empower a lot of people to
have the freedom to run their own
businesses and have a nice life and then
use that capital to do more interesting
things instead of being a developer at
Facebook or something yeah I think part
of what at least fascinates me from what
I understand about the businesses you
guys own there's a lot of venture
capitalists and private equity folks who
would look and say you know what is the
mode the I only invest in infrastructure
businesses and they kind of have this
cookie cutter approach to to what they
will invest in or buy with you you
actually appear to be willing to go kind
of the full stack so everything from
marketplaces like the dribbles of the
world except sure all the way to a
furniture business which is really just
an e-commerce store right and you're
selling any widget through that but it
happens to be a really nicely done piece
of furniture and so it feels to me like
the no code movement really empowers
some of the things that are actually
outside of the sweet spot of most
venture capitalist and private equity
folks you mentioned it based on scale
but also it almost seems like the types
of businesses as well right I don't know
how many of them are going out looking
for kind of I want to invest in a
furniture manufacturer right that sells
online maybe at some you know huge scale
that you know and kind of blitzscale it
if you will but what you guys are really
building there it seems like that would
be outside their wheelhouse something
like no code and powers that to be done
quickly though is that fair to say yeah
I mean I think no code empowers both
venture businesses and normal but you
know just run-of-the-mill sustainability
simple $200,000 your lifestyle
businesses what is interesting is
there's a company we invested in called
flytographer which is a global network
of travel photographers so the idea is
let's say you're in Italy in Venice and
you want to you know remember that trip
forever and so you schedule a Travel
Photographer to show up in a square at a
certain time and take photos of you and
your family and it's super Pro since
they're having crappy photos by dad you
got this beautiful photo album and it
was really interesting the founder she
originally for the first two years of
the business just had a Squarespace
website a very well designed Squarespace
website you wouldn't know if you looked
at it and it was a forum and so you
basically would click through and then
there'd be a series of questions of
where are you and you know you want a
book and what city are you in and all
this kind of stuff and she actually got
to hundreds of thousands or maybe even
millions of dollars of revenue off of
the Squarespace site before then going
out raising money and hiring a bunch of
people and what it enabled her to do was
validate the idea but also she could
delay raising money and by delaying
raising money she increased her
potential evaluation for her first raise
so she owns way more of the business
than she would have if she'd gone out
raised angel round and a seed round
before getting revenue so I think stuff
like that is super interesting and
that's a very old-school version of that
that's just a Squarespace site think
about like somebody who does like a
marketplace or you know Airbnb style
website it could get pretty far on no
code yeah it's really interesting to me
because I think that the no code
movement is like a technical trend
that is now matching people who are on
this almost Ethos trend of we're seeing
many many people who previously may have
raised venture capital not raise money
now right and kind of go further earlier
in the days some of them then eventually
raise capital but too specifically that
I'm interested in and I know that one of
them you've written about is the kylie
jenner's and the Joe Rogan's of the
world right people who end up building
these tens of millions hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue never
raised a dollar right and actually have
pretty small teams and it's all because
either one they didn't know that that
was a thing that you do or two they
could just self fund it right and it
just took many years to grow in Rogen's
case and so maybe talk a little bit
about how you see entrepreneurs
themselves and like their relationship
with venture capital as no code becomes
more popular accessory do you think that
there will be a material change in the
way that these companies are funded at
the earliest stages or do you think
that's a lot of speculation that's out
there and instead people will continue
to go seek venture capital and and and
what kind of a lot of the same moving
forward well I think the problem is that
and there's so much venture money out
there now and there's this kind of story
perpetuated by a lot of I mean you look
at like how I built this or some of
these shows it almost always starts with
you know oh I went out and I raised
money from a venture capitalist maybe
not everyone there's lots great stories
of people who didn't but typically the
story is either I couldn't get venture
capital and I tried or you know I did
and that's how I got started and the
problem with venture capital is the only
people you hear from are the Jeff Bezos
of the world not the Jeff Bezos is who
you know lost all their money and failed
and so it's a little bit like you know
if you have a gazelle if a thousand
gazelles cross a crocodile-infested
stream and one gets across write the
rest them all get eaten by crocodiles
that one gazelle is gonna go you know
what I should go interview on how I
built this and I should write a business
book I'm a genius and in reality many of
these people got very lucky or we're
very very very talented and you know
we're able to pull it off but the big
thing about venture is that it hasn't
ninety-five percent failure rate so when
you sign up for venture what you're
doing is you're putting a gun to your
head right and you know it makes perfect
sense based on the venture incentives
they're making many many bets they're
making 20 bets hoping that one turns
into a billion-dollar business but
suddenly you're signing up for that
you're saying I'm gonna take $1 and I'm
gonna turn it into 10 or 20 dollars at a
minimum and in order to do that you have
to grow at all costs and so even if you
build a sustainable business that's good
for you personally if you have venture
on your cap table you have a crazy
incentive and your investors have an
incentive to push you like crazy and my
fundamental belief is that there's not
that many businesses that are well
suited to venture I think a lot of these
business models that have been funded
are perfectly good businesses that could
have compounded their own capital and
grown to a good sustainable scale but
they've been over funded and you can see
that I mean if you look at all these
businesses funded by Softbank half of
them are going bankrupt now I mean zoom
Pizza it's insane they got two hundred
million dollars or something and somehow
you know now they're laying people off
and didn't work and I do I always wonder
like if they just kept working and
slowly evolving that overtime with some
you know a lesser amount of money what
would have happened there so I always
think like Capital creates a lack of
discipline often and so it can be really
bad I mean there's no there's no doubt
that if you're going out and you're
starting a consumer social network yeah
you got to go raise venture because it's
winner take all you have to build a
network effect but if you're building a
business that is you know simple and
sustainable I I see no reason to raise
venture and I don't think people
understand that it's a high interest
credit card right at the end of the day
that's what you're that's what you're
getting and it's much better to get
boring 3% bank loans yeah it's really
interesting too I think because when you
take that money given their return
expectations you're actually probably
decreasing the probability of success
because you're signing up to do
something that's much harder than just
build us a stable business but with that
kind of increased difficulty comes the
potential
for increased return as well right so
you kind of have you have the
possibility of bigger return it's just
harder to get there and I think that
that kind of gets lost because we've
almost celebrit eyes to the venture
capital the problem is people forget
that people who are CEOs have now public
billion-dollar companies many of them
have been diluted they own 10% or 5% or
whatever and so even if you have a
billion-dollar business
maybe you're worth fifty a hundred two
hundred million dollars it's a lot of
money but what they forget is that if
you just had a good profitable business
that if you can get to a million dollars
a year of earnings and you keep
compounding at fifteen or twenty percent
a year which i think is realistic for
you know a reasonable business on the
internet you can become worth hundreds
of millions of dollars in a very
conservative boring way right and so I
think if you look at Buffett's example
of the snowball where as slowly as
compounding as capital it's very
different from trying to go out and do
something massive and take crazy risk
and be that one gazelle so you've
obviously spent a lot of time thinking
about subscription podcast and you
recently wrote a piece about how Joe
Rogan basically could be making more
money through subscription rather than
ads or or the deal he did you had
originally made the analysis on Howard
Stern and the serious deal so maybe give
us just kind of a 1-minute summary of
the math that you're using there in the
logic behind why Rogan or somebody else
going subscription versus ads makes more
sense yeah so I think um you know I've
described it as podcasters are a bunch
of farmers and they on fertile land
right they they their only way of making
money off the land is to grow vegetables
which is a lot of work it's
back-breaking labor right and that's
advertising so they do the advertising
it's a pain in the ass to sell they have
to have some douchey salesperson who
does all the ad sales they're
negotiating and a lot of podcasters
there are often public intellectuals or
non businesspeople so to them often
they're kind of allergic to that idea
and they don't want to deal with that
and so when someone like Spotify comes
along and says look you're making twenty
million dollars a year we'll give you
2530 and come over and we'll deal with
all your ad sales I think that's very
very attractive to them what I've been
making the case for is that there's
actually a lot of oil beneath the
farmland and that's the real value and
the oil is recurring membership
subscription so when Howard Stern went
to Sirius he had this huge public radio
or not public radio but private you know
FM radio listenership of you know I
think it was like 5 10 15 million people
every day tuned in to listen to Howard
and when he went to Sirius they fully
gated him so they said past 19 bucks a
month and you can listen to Howard Stern
otherwise you can write and in doing so
that drove massive revenue we kind of
did some napkin in math we estimate
probably between 300 and 400 million
dollars a year of serious revenue as
just people who want to listen to Howard
Stern right when he did that deal he
could not have gone out and started his
own radio station and bought satellites
and done all this stuff and cut out the
middleman there had to be a middleman
either it was an FM radio and a network
or it was satellite radio they made him
the best deal my argument with Howard
Stern is that Stern should just cut out
the middleman that all the technology
that has been developed over the last
decade in podcasting makes all of their
satellites and distribution completely
irrelevant my argument is that Stern
should leave Sirius he should start a
podcast and he should basically have the
podcast cut off after 30 minutes similar
to what Sam Harris does or 10 minutes or
maybe it's only for subscribers and he
should rebuild his audience there via
subscription and charge the same amount
Sirius was charging except he gets a
hundred percent of it and if you look at
his business he needs a microphone he
needs an internet connection maybe needs
a talent Booker and you know maybe an
assistant or something so he can make 90
98 99 percent net margins so that was
about six or seven months ago and in
that same article I basically said look
Joe Rogan is 10 times bigger than the
current audience of you know serious and
and
Howard Stern it's insane that he's
probably a billionaire and he just
doesn't know it yet he's got billions of
dollars of oil under his farm and so
Rogan you know he could go Subscription
just like Howard Stern and do his own
deal he could just say now you got to
pay to listen to me let's do that
that doesn't seem like his vibe so what
I'm basically estimating is if he simply
just said one Episode a week or the last
twenty minutes of every episode is
subscriber only they're still going to
be ads and if you subscribe you get an
ad-free stream so the ads that are
edited out and you get the extra twenty
minutes at the end of every episode or
one extra episode a week or something
and maybe some kind of exclusive content
for true fans maybe streaming video or
something like that
and if you just assume a 5% conversion
rate which is you know maybe his most
loyal fans the numbers are staggering
right so I asked me he could do
somewhere between sixty to a hundred
million dollars a year at a minimum with
that hybrid approach maybe more than
that if he was a little more aggressive
and so you know as a businessperson I
look at this and I go this is very very
easy to execute this does not require
advanced technology it doesn't acquire
crazy business management it doesn't
require a big team he could easily do
that tomorrow and yet he ended up opting
to go to Spotify and while I don't know
the exact terms of his deal from what's
been reported in the Wall Street Journal
and stuff it's somewhere in the range of
50 to a hundred million dollars that's
unclear of exactly how its structured
whether that's an annual thing or
whatever now everybody's saying well he
just licensed it so he just gave them
three years exclusive to go to Spotify
what I the reason why I think that's a
bad deal even let's say lifestyle-wise
he just hates selling ads he doesn't
want to deal with he doesn't want to
think about this stuff I think it's a
bad deal because at the end of the day
these guys want impact they want to be
heard by as many people as possible and
they have this loudspeaker and I think
they like that what he's doing is giving
over his direct line of communication to
his listeners his podcast feed and
interact relationship where
he can put anything he wants in that
feed and it goes directly to the
subscribers he's now given that to
Spotify and Spotify is in the middle of
that and what it means is that over the
next three years if his audience doubles
when he leaves Spotify he loses all
those new subscribers and yeah maybe
they'll go find him once he leaves but
he loses that direct relationship and so
to me you never want to lose your direct
relationship with your customer when
you're an influencer to me it's like
imagine if Kylie Jenner or someone
that's huge on Twitter went out and said
hey guys I've sold my Twitter rights to
I don't know CNN and now CNN is gonna
tweet on my behalf so you're losing all
those subscribers and all those
followers
so while objectively Joe Rogan is
killing it and Howard Stern is killing
it - he's guys made 500 million dollars
or whatever I'm not criticizing that as
a business strategist I think it's
insane I think it's totally the wrong
move and I think that Rogan he was just
sitting on oil and he didn't know how to
drill it and he wasn't even aware of it
and so my argument is that she'd just do
it himself but too late for that yeah
and I think part of this like Howard
Stern actually went deep after I read
your piece and went back and it's hard
to remember Howard Stern signed that
original you know hundred million
dollars a year for five years in 2004
and so I said you know what what's he
been getting paid since then and he
basically signed a 12-year deal and the
other day the point I found is the
estimate that he made about 90 million
dollars last year so there's a good
chance he's been getting paid you know
eighty to a hundred million bucks a year
for over a decade now right and so Bobby
would say hey that's not that big of a
deal but to your point I think that the
numbers are like close to only a million
people or so are listening to the show
now versus you see a rogue in who maybe
it's not directly competitive in terms
of the content but it's very similar and
he's got you know five or ten or fifteen
times the size of the audience and so
what that then leads to is this idea of
like the creator used to be very similar
to an actor right hey you select me I
participate in your movie you pay me a
fee and I move on and that's basically
what they were doing with advertisers
but now we're seeing across platforms
whether it's tick tock stars YouTube
podcaster
whatever they're building real
businesses right and they're looking at
this as I need diversified revenue
streams and and they understand that the
value is in that audience and so Kylie's
probably the best example where she
built a billion-dollar business off the
back of having that audience but are you
seeing other creators maybe people who
are using kind of paid podcasts and they
have other tools or just people who
haven't gotten into paid podcast yet but
they're building these multiple revenue
streams and can you talk a little bit
about how you see that playing out over
time yeah I mean I think um you know if
you look at like 1998 the model used to
be okay I'm gonna start a dumb you know
yo mama joke website on Yahoo and I'm
gonna put a bunch of ugly banners on it
right I think that's the era of
podcasting we're in right now and I
think that people will realize that not
only is it better to have subscriber
support because you get more buy-in
people are more loyal and and you don't
really owe anyone anything
you can talk about any brand you can say
anything you want there's no advertisers
to pull their advertising as long as
your audience likes you oaky paying you
but that it's recurring and it's higher
margin because you're not you know I've
had going through ad sales or anything
like that and I think for a lot of
podcasters they're anxious because they
have all these ads on but they don't
know maybe the CPM rates drop like crazy
in six months maybe all the startups go
away and they're they're not gonna fund
podcast advertising maybe Squarespace
lowers the budget may be audible lowers
the budget right so I think that it's
just a better model and we're seeing
this across all media that ultimately
subscription for software newsletters
podcasting etc it's just it's just
better in so many ways so I think that
over time that realization is gonna hit
and if you think about it there's
already all these models already exist
in plain sight right you look at Ben
Thompson that strategy has been writing
a subscription newsletter that's pay
only with a few pieces of content
previewed for free publicly since 2014 I
think I don't know anything I think he's
making millions of dollars doing that
and now it wasn't until 2019 that sub
stack popped up and all these writers
started going hey I can go direct
consumer I don't need to go work for New
York Times they can write my own
newsletter and as long as I have a
thousand true fans I can make a living
and over time I can compound those fans
and grow it significantly you know in
the podcasting world Sam Harris has been
doing this since 2013 right and he
doesn't have any advertising I have no
idea what he's doing revenue wise but I
would assume he's doing well if it's
still working and he just doubled down
on his subscription stuff now after 30
minutes it just cuts off and he says hey
if you want to keep listening on every
single episode you've got to pay so I I
think there's people that are doing it
very successfully and we've helped
people with super cast and with our art
podcast agency double-up we've helped
all sorts of people find the oil
underneath their plot of land you know
be we've I can't name names but there's
multiple people who are like influencers
with huge audiences and they were making
so little money off it because they're
not business people right and so we were
able to help them you know build a
sustainable business and that's such a
cool thing for us right to show people
hey you know you're you're a farmer but
now you're you know we're worth 10
million dollars right yeah I think this
brings up a really interesting point
around kind of the creators versus the
business people there are some people
who obviously are great business people
and and great creators but there is
definitely a number of creators that
they just either aren't intellectually
interested in it they have no experience
whatever it is but it's pretty simple
mechanism to say hey I create something
and you pay me for it right like that's
not rocket science that the challenge is
just how do you actually do that and
part of what I think you guys have built
with the paid podcast platform is the
technology previously wasn't there right
because part of what I think Sam Harris
and others had to do is headed build one
with these like custom platforms that
again going back to there's no no code
for it right you actually had to get a
developer and there was just a very big
heavy lift and so now that there's the
reduction in friction I'm assuming that
we will see many more people go do this
but you know obviously time will tell
yeah I mean I think you know if you talk
to someone who writes a newsletter
nobody says oh my god how do I use
MailChimp
right or how do I do a Squarespace
website what they don't realize is that
doing this subscription podcast thing is
just as easy
like there's no major development
required it's as simple as signing up
for super cast or Glo or one of the
services and putting a link in your show
notes and then you have the second feed
for subscribers and you just start once
in a while doing an AMA and then on the
other feed the public feed you might
tease it hey we didn't AMA today here's
the first 15 minutes if you want to
listen the whole thing subscribe and I'm
just going crazy like I feel like I'm in
the upside down and stranger things and
I'm just like screaming at all these
people saying like you're rich like go
and do this it's so much better and it
appears that people are catching on
right but you know you look at there's
been stuff like Tim Ferriss came out and
did an experiment with his and you know
kudos to Tim for trying it and he
decided it's not for him and that's fine
he's a great business regardless but I
think like his pricing and the value
proposition just wasn't there I think he
was charging significantly more than
most of their podcasts and he wasn't
really offering too much in response he
wasn't saying I'm gonna give you a bunch
of exclusive content or anything so
stuff like that has set this back a
little bit which is fine because there's
a lot of oil for us to go slurp up right
so we're thinking about how can we go
out and do deals with podcasters where
we say look we'll give you if the
audience is big enough we'll give you
millions of dollars and we'll do a
revenue share on whatever your revenue
is or something like that so I think
everyone's gonna catch on over the next
couple years though we just need we need
a Joe Rogan or someone like that to do
this yeah it's funny how once you hear
that oh it worked for somebody that
everyone wants to do it right and I
think Ben Thompson is a great example on
the newsletter side but it also works
against you right and when you bring up
Ferriss with kind of he tried it not
definite heard a lot of people say oh
well he tried it didn't work right and
so kind of nuanced matters there I want
to talk a little bit about kind of
note-taking in the organization of
information I know you've been talking a
lot about Rome research and kind of this
product where you can essentially
download your brain
maybe talk a little bit just about like
where the intellectual curiosity for you
comes from around that type of software
or use case and then we can talk about
Rome research itself I'm not really big
into note-taking like I've always been I
use Apple no it's all right down you
know simple to-do list or something like
that but I'm a big to-do list person so
I've been using the getting things done
framework and OmniFocus and nerding out
on that for years and years and years
but note-taking was always this thing
that I kind of went like why do people
do this right they're writing all their
ideas down and then there's no way to
resurface them so I've tried journaling
and all that kind of stuff and it always
just felt like okay well I got it out of
my head but I'm never gonna look at this
again and I'm when am I ever gonna go
back and go what was I thinking on April
you know April 24th of 2018 so then I
start seeing everybody posting about
Rome which is this new hot fuzzy
note-taking software and it's it's quite
interesting it's kind of like um
Wikipedia like a personal Wikipedia
right so like any other app you would go
in and you'd write a daily note or you
know whatever you're thinking about but
you can tag or link different ideas
together so an example is you know I
look at my sleep and I'll write out here
here's how I slept last night I've been
going through a period where I just
haven't been sleeping well and I'm
trying to figure out what it is and so
I'll write like a little sleep journal
and as I do it I might say I should try
intermittent fasting and what I can do
is I can click on I can make
intermittent fasting a page like
Wikipedia and I can click that and then
I can see every single time I've ever
referenced intermittent fasting so for
example I could go and like what during
what periods of my life have I been
doing that and how did I feel how did it
affect me or what of my feelings been
about this specific person I work with
like it's quite interesting and I don't
know if I'm gonna stick with it or
whether that's super valuable but it is
interesting and I think that there's an
opportunity for them to make
this into something that's way more
extensible with an API where I can just
dump my brain in every morning and have
it kind of put stuff out to Twitter or
send an email do other stuff yeah at
this point it's more of a curiosity it's
something that's interesting yeah and I
think my interest in this type of stuff
is if you think of your brain as a
computer right we just run into
limitations and so you can't possibly
remember everything or think back to a
certain date with the accuracy you need
etc it almost kind of feels like you're
trying to in some weird way like index
your brain on a daily basis and I love
your example about kind of the
journaling of like great I wrote it but
like I'm never going to go back and read
it right or maybe I'll go read it five
years from now or you know next year as
a review type thing I guess part of it
is do you tend to think back to solve
the problem so when you say like
sleeping for example if you weren't
writing this stuff down at something
like Rome are you the type of person who
would normally say hey you know what
I've actually slept pretty good this
week and I kind of tested intermittent
fasting I think that that's what what
solved it or did you feel kind of blind
to a lot of this and that's where the
interest in journaling came from yeah I
think it's living in a fog right where
you kind of forget I mean yeah you you
you could ask the how was your weekend
and I'd be like oh I don't really know
how I felt or how have my weekends been
lately I would only have the context of
whatever happened really recently and
again I've only been doing this for
about a month now I've started to you
know starting to link these thoughts
together and do this stuff I think the
fundamental question though is and it
seemed the same thing is true for
getting things done
the system works really well if you
follow it very strictly and but you do
get into this situation where you end up
living and breathing this product and so
the problem is you're like okay should I
be sitting in this meeting constantly
writing everything down or during the
meeting am I writing shorthand notes and
then putting them in later and by doing
that I just killed an hour am I gonna
get future value or do these notes or
not and if I'm not always getting value
or the notes I think it becomes this
thing where
the process becomes too all-consuming
and so I found this with gang things
done like I use it loosely but there's
people where it's like every single
thing in their life like if there's a
scratch on their hardwood floor they're
like oh I need to take this as home and
you know schedule it and stuff I'm not
like that
so I mean again with any of these
systems all the productivity nerds get
excited about them and in reality
they're only as good as the inputs it
kind of reminds me of a calendar right
I'm one of these people like it was on
my calendar I will not show up right cuz
and literally because I'm like too dumb
to remember um calendar is just
literally notes so that makes a lot of
sense when I told people that you were
going to come on I had a lot of
questions around kind of getting started
and a lot of things that seemed like
people asking questions around how much
money is needed to get started and
things that I look at is almost like
planning to go into this it sounds like
you were much more kind of backing into
it but any thoughts around if you were
gonna restart tiny and this type of
business today kind of what those
foundational components would be to
really put yourself in a position to be
successful yeah I mean I always think I
talked a lot about like Launchpad
businesses so this idea of let's say you
want to be you on musk and you want to
launch the next space mission there's
two ways to go about doing that and if
you're inexperienced you know one's very
high-risk so let's say that you're 20
years old and you want to go start the
next SpaceX you can go and convince a
bunch of investors give you money which
might be very hard and because you're
inexperienced you'll probably fail and
because you raised venture there's even
more risk right I always think that the
whole point of entrepreneurship is
freedom at its core right people want to
be able to get up in their day and work
on something they're passionate about
with people they like and they don't
want people to tell them what to do
that's it that's where it is for me at
least and so if you think about it like
you really want to tick off your
Maslow's hierarchy of needs before
anything else so I want to be able to
pay my rent
live a comfortable life drive a car go
out for dinner and not worry about it
all those things
so what I really look for is a first
business that's simple and it doesn't
have to be scalable it doesn't have to
be a venture scale billion-dollar idea
it can be something very very boring and
the idea would be to build a business
that can get you 50 to $200,000 a year
and give you a permanent base or at
least a short trim base so you can go
and launch like your crazy ideas with
less less risk and so you know I use
things in Apple there's a guy I know who
found like a it's a table a specific
table like a furniture table that's kind
of classic and it's been ripped off and
replicated a whole bunch and so he went
out he bought all the replicas he
reviewed them on a website and he said
you ranked them this is the best one and
then he went out and he did a bunch of
SEO made sure it got a bunch of traffic
on Google and then he did affiliate and
so he gets paid a feed whenever someone
buys one of these replicas and the
business makes him fifty to a hundred
thousand dollars a year and it probably
took him three or four days to put the
business together sends a couple hours a
month on it and I just think that's the
magic of internet businesses so I think
if someone depends on what someone wants
to do but if they're starting a business
I think the goal should be yeah fifty to
two hundred thousand dollars a year and
then go off and do the crazy stuff and
whatever else but there's a kind of a
profound sense of security from having
something like that yeah and I forget
unfortunately who I heard this from but
just recently I heard somebody talking
about kind of rather than going out and
getting ten different revenue streams
like finding one that's the cash cow
doubling and tripling down on that
really get it kind of rockin and then
diversifying out and they were using
examples like you know Google with the
search engine right or Amazon and all
these businesses that we know now that
are great businesses it feels like you
would be an advocate for doing the same
thing in starting a business in kind of
these non scalable versions as well or
non venture back of all versions as well
is that fair
well I mean I think those businesses
have Network effects right so you if if
there's a business there's a business
that we are shareholders in it is a
network of clinic
of medical clinics all over Canada so
it's basically clinic wait times right
and when the guy was starting it so this
guy comes to me and he says look I'm
gonna start this network of walk-in
clinics in Canada it's like Soviet
Russia we have all these like you know
government and you know poorly operated
clinics and there's these long waits so
if you're if you need medical attention
it's gonna take you three four or five
hours of sitting in a room with a bunch
of sick people so you want to make sure
that's the shortest possible wait and
what used to have to do is call so you'd
call five clinics you'd go to whatever
one had the shortest wait and the clinic
operators hated getting these phone
calls because they'd have these MOS that
would just sit there and answer the
phone all day and so human oh and he
went to all of the clinics and he said
hey why don't you just tell everyone to
go to Medi map dossier which is his
website and we're gonna make a map of
all the clinics in your city and show
the wait times and so he got them all to
install software that pops up every 30
minutes and says update the wait time so
he managed to pull it off we ended up
investing significantly in the business
and he had no revenue model whatsoever
which is not something I normally would
invest in but what I saw was a network
effect I saw that he at the time we
invested had 60 percent of all walk-in
clinics in Canada on this network and
now he has something like 86 percent or
something so that's a situation where
when you have a network effect like that
it makes it impossible to compete with
no one can start tell us or any of these
big multi multinational billion-dollar
corporations they can't go out and go to
all the clinics and say we'll pay you
ten thousand dollars and whatever it's
gonna be too much of a pain in the ass
and doesn't make sense and so in that
business we said don't worry about
revenue don't worry about any other
monetization just get every clinic in
Canada using this and then we'll worry
about monetization so that's an example
of a business where the network effect
and building that most important thing
like Google nailing search and becoming
a verb was really important but a lot of
these businesses I'm thinking of her
more boring they're like you know I know
a guy who runs it Sal it's a newsletter
and he just goes out and he buys 10
domains a day like just weird dough man
so be like
you lace does not go or whatever and he
buys ten of them and it's just a
newsletter where he sends them out and
he buys them for ten bucks and he sells
them for a hundred or a thousand and
there's all these domain nerds and they
all follow him on this newsletter and
they just keep buying his domains and it
takes him an hour a day or something and
he makes good money from that so that's
what I mean about a dead simple dumb
business that just gives you that
cushion and pays your bills I'm not
talking about the network effect and
Amazon or anything like that
when I hear businesses like that it
always cracks me up because the people
behind a business that like the domain
business is just a resourceful person
right it's somebody who literally
figured out hey here is a little niche
of the world that there's just enough
interest where I can build a business
and and almost optimize kind of the time
invested for capital received right it's
all I had a problem I'm gonna solve this
for myself and there's got to be you
know a thousand other people who agree
for sure I've heard on other podcast
you've talked about kind of this
internal narrative that that you spend
time on what are some of the internal
narratives that you're talking about now
or telling yourself given that were you
know kind of two and a half months or so
into this economic shock and and kind of
a lot of the uncertainty that's in the
world there's in the internal narrative
stuff there that that would be
interesting to folks well I'm trying to
remind myself that when horrible things
happen there's almost always opportunity
because it's kind of like a forest fire
right so forest fire rips through and a
lot of destruction happens right a lot
of venture businesses go to business a
lot of you know big businesses like
Hertz go out of business and I think
there's always opportunities there to
start a business when Matt there's
maximum pessimism because you don't have
as many competitors and I think over the
last 10 years there's been nothing but
unbridled optimism and so it's made it a
challenging business environment whether
you were starting you know a delivery
business you're gonna get venture
competition any kind of software
business almost every single vertical is
hyper competitive because adventure and
so I think that'll probably
we slowdown and there'll be some level
of Correction there which I think in
many ways despite being very sad for the
people whose businesses are going to
struggle or go to business I think it's
probably you know of benefits and you
know entrepreneurs so I'm excited about
that I'm really just trying to remember
that the world has been really boring
for the last 40 years and that my
grandparents and great-grandparents
lived through times that were way more
harrowing I mean they weren't sitting
when the 1918 flu pandemic happened they
would just pick up the newspaper one day
and they would say you know a thousand
people just died and we don't know what
to do about it and you should squirt
porridge up your nose and all these
ridiculous folk remedies and you know
they all saw a fountain my my great aunt
died of the Spanish flu they weren't
sitting at home on Netflix and you know
they didn't have therapeutic drugs and
stuff so I'm trying to just remind
myself that this is not the worst thing
that's happened to anybody
and that we're in the first world and to
be grateful but you know it's it's a
very odd time it's fine and it's hard
because on one hand as a businessperson
I'm very optimistic and excited about
the opportunity coming and you know the
businesses it'll get started as a result
of this but as a human you know there's
a lot of crazy stuff going on in the
world right now
and it certainly makes me feel nervous
and cautious yeah I think that's great
kind of reminder that we're all gonna
die one day - right so it's great
perspective the last thing I want to end
talking about is this idea of kind of a
venture-backed graveyard right and what
I mean by that is there's been an
explosion of companies over the last
five to ten years that have been backed
through venture capital many of them on
the day they took that venture capital
believed they were gonna build the next
great you know billion dollar plus
start-up venture capitalists believe
that and everyone kind of gave it their
best effort right but where we find them
today is it didn't play out the way that
everyone thought it was and so that may
be because of things under their control
or not under their control there's kind
of a whole gamut there but my question
to you is given the model that
you've employed do you think that there
is a opportunity to go get the
previously venture capital funded
businesses that didn't scale to those
billion-dollar companies and start to
actually kind of wean them off the
dependency on venture capital and push
them into something that looks more like
I'll call kind of a tiny business
meaning the businesses that you guys
normally look at like can you transition
or is it once they've taken the venture
capital no matter how badly it goes it's
kind of a fatal shot and they can't
transition back to a sustainable
business model I think it's like drug
addiction right so it's like heroin you
shoot heroin a couple times there's
people who get out and then there's
people who just they unfortunately don't
do well with it and so I think that I'm
really really excited whenever we got
the opportunity to take a venture back
business and dust it off and clean up
the PNL and get it back to its former
glory that's really exciting we just did
that with a business called meteor that
we bought that andreessen horowitz had
put 50 million dollars into and it was a
wonderful business and had great
customers and was growing at 30 plus
percent a year but it just wasn't
growing at a hundred or 200 percent a
year and so the business had to pivot
and when they pivoted there was this
whorfin business leftover and it was
really cool we were able to buy it and
reengage the community and plug in a
great team and start actively working on
it again so that's been really cool and
I think there's gonna be a lot of
opportunities like that over the next
year or two I think that venture it's
not that venture is gonna go away it's
that venture is only gonna fund the very
best deals so you see this with
companies like notion that are
incredibly hot they're growing really
fast or in a great space they've got all
the right metrics those guys will be
able to raise fine but the business
that's growing at 20% a year 30% a year
40% a year even may not be able to raise
or if it's just a slightly more
challenging environment and I think
those are the opportunities that we're
very excited about where we can help
them we knopf the venture juice and
build a sustainable business and there's
obviously pain associated with that
right a lot of these companies have been
run
in ways that their P&L is just totally
out of whack and you know they they've
done some crazy stuff and we see P&L s
of these businesses every day and it
just boggles the mind we we basically
we've been around for 15 years for the
first ten years we couldn't even get a
bank loan we could barely get credit
cards right we just had no access to
capital at all and it made us incredibly
incredibly disciplined piano operators
we had to be otherwise we'd go to
business that was all we had and so when
I see these businesses it's just blows
my mind like I can't believe how much
money they burn and it's staggering can
you take a business that's done that
right and to be clear I think you're
saying this as well as I am that's the
model they're in right so it's not like
they're doing anything that's malicious
or bad it's just they've been given a
lot of money and use the money to grow
right but if you have a team that has
through muscle memory been trained to
spend a lot of money and try to hit that
high growth is it possible to then take
that business with the same team and
kind of retrain them to go after the
more sustainable model or like in the
business that you bought do you have to
basically bring in a new team and then
you can just take the actual assets with
a new team and can do it I mean we
talked to founders all the time who say
I wish I never is venture this isn't
right for me I don't want to shoot for
the moon I'm risk-averse can you buy out
my venture investors and we look at
those deals all the time in that
instance yes because they've self opted
into that and they think so if I had a
venture investor private equity investor
come to me and say hey look I own 60% of
this business you know they burned
through all this money and they're not
in that camp that's a totally different
story we would really have to think hard
about that because not only are you
doing management change but you're
changing the business model and the P&L
and stuff well we would look for in a
venture back business is something that
is ultimately sustainable with high
margins that's simple and is still doing
well despite having this crazy venture
stuff going on what kills me is seeing
these businesses where the unit
economics don't make sense where they
spend five dollars to make one dollar of
revenue
and then they burn $3 in operating costs
or whatever those are the businesses we
would not be interested in the ones that
I love are the ones where if you just
dust off the P&L a little bit and you
operate it a little more conservatively
there's a wonderful profitable business
underneath yeah the speaking of kind of
these d2c companies or the high CAC type
businesses I think it goes back to our
conversation with the Joe Rogan's the
Kylie Jenner's like I think we're seeing
the rise of entrepreneurs who are able
to drastically reduce that cost of
acquisition because they have the
built-in audience right where you're
almost seeing the business models that
didn't work five years ago will come
back it'll just be with a different unit
economic basis and it's because the
person now started a company will
actually have the customers there rather
than have to go acquire them yeah if you
own an amazing busy office building and
you have tens of thousands of people in
a lobby and you can start your own
coffee shop and put it in there you're
gonna sell a lot of coffee no matter
what you do it could be the worst coffee
in the world
I think that's what you see with Kylie
Jenner is she starts a makeup brand it
barely matters it's just branded and hot
and she can promote it on her own
channel for free I think there's gonna
be a lot more of that happening and I
again like going back to she's done this
you know she's become a billionaire I
don't know what the exact numbers would
look like or whatever but I think if you
think about it if she could do a digital
product right where she can actually
have true 95 or 99 percent margins
that's where things can get really crazy
like the Rogan kind of members
especially if it's recurring revenue
because at the end of the day then you
have the best SAS business in the world
you have no rnd cost yeah and I guess as
part of that do you think that's where
this goes like do you see a world where
these influencers start to get away from
building merch and kind of the easy kind
of low hanging fruit stuff and they
actually started to say I want to build
software products whether they're mobile
apps or web-based stuff and that's like
that becomes the Holy Grail well you
look at Sam Harris you know he has this
huge podcast he's doing this
subscription thing
and then we helped him build his
meditation app right and it's the exact
same thing he's publicly speaking about
meditation he's written books about it
and he has a loyal audience well it's
perfectly logical to say hey you should
use my meditation app you know me you
trust me and I have this free
acquisition channel you know and now
he's got this whole other business right
there that you know it wasn't that
complicated for us to help him we used
metal a band metal I built built the
meditation app and designed it and you
know I think it was profitable
relatively quickly
yeah that makes a ton of sense before we
we wrap up bias everyone the same two
questions the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
well the book I go back to most is it's
actually a compilation of quotes by
Charlie Munger and Charlie Munger is
like the lesser-known number two -
Warren Buffett and he's like super super
interesting Buffett if you watch his
interviews he says the same thing a lot
is very interesting but he says the same
thing mongers like a you know he's like
John Coltrane he just goes all over the
place and says all sorts of interesting
stuff but it's just a complication of
quotes by him called the Tao of Charlie
Munger and it basically is all his most
important quotes and then kind of
explained underneath and surprisingly I
never expected to like this book but
it's become this thing that I go back to
over and over and over again I listen to
it as an audiobook in the car I've
probably listened to it like 300 times
but I would say everything you need to
know about business is in that book like
I think he's by far the best business
person in the world I thought you were
gonna say you've read it like 10 times
not 300 300 a lot for like three four
years I listened to it like once a week
I loved that last question is alien this
believer or non-believer Wow curveball
I think logically it they probably do
exist but I'd question whether or not
we've actually had any interaction with
them I saw some of these crazy videos
though so i don't know i i'd say
extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence so we're
gonna need to see some evidence yeah
what what is the logic behind they
probably exist well I think that the
universe is so big that I would say
probabilistically odds are they do but
whether or not we would ever interact
with them or cross paths I mean who
knows right for sure and then to end it
you gotta ask me one question what is
the one question you have for me so I've
been you know I've been very interested
in crypto from the perspective of
enabling micro transactions or live
commerce right so this idea of like if I
work for thirty seconds I can get paid
thirty seconds worth of tokens or
whatever what I've been very interested
in crypto but it kind of feels like
we're in 1997 still right and everyone's
getting really excited about this
technology but the actual use cases are
yet to come through and it's been three
or four years where there's been heavy
venture investment what do you see as
the most interesting real business that
has real revenue and real profit or the
potential to do something significant so
let me go back so there's two or three
questions in there a huge believer in I
call it streaming payments or kind of
micro payment so you described and the
use case I always go to is like I think
a lot of people look at like 30 seconds
worth of work and they're like that's
ridiculous
right and so I say hey look if you kind
of extrapolate that out like why do you
go home today from your job and you
didn't get a paycheck right why do you
have to wait two weeks to get it and so
just like little things like that I
think people like Oh that'd be awesome
if I got a paycheck today and tomorrow
got another one I do think that that
will happen I think that crypto and
Bitcoin and things like that will make
it possible but I do think that there's
like consumer behavior changes that have
to happen both at the corporate level
and for the individual so some of that
is still at play in terms of like where
we are I think you're being overly
generous saying we're in 1997 I actually
take the stance of like we're probably
in the like early 1990-1992 somewhere in
there
and the reason why I say that is like if
you remember back even into like the
mid-90s AOL dial-up like there was still
the noise and you only could use you
know one phone line and if you were on
the internet your parents couldn't use
the phone and they were yelling at you
and like all of those things that I
think you know people probably your age
my age like [ __ ] nostalgia of like oh I
remember those days that's basically
what's happening in crypto now right is
just like it is really hard to use right
and that has to improve over time to get
the mass adoption that just comes with
time though and so I think that's kind
of like the trajectory of just reminding
ourselves like if you go look at
Amazon's first web site compared today
today's standards it looks ridiculous
back then like it was great right and so
that'll happening in crypto as well but
in terms of the companies like I would
say that pretty much hands down the best
businesses as a kind of group has been
the exchanges so the whole idea of us
coinbase gemini by Nance cracking yeah
just go down the line all of them so
that's been interesting one of the
businesses that we funded it's gonna be
called block Phi that basically is
building out all the financial services
or they use the terminology wealth
management so you give them crypto
they'll give you US dollar alone you can
put an interest-bearing accounts write
all these kind of products that really
treat they benefit from speculation so
like now what I'm really wondering is so
like coin base to make a lot of money
even if it's just a bunch of people
speculating and buying the currency or
whatever and I totally agree like we've
known Brian at coin base since a1
basically we help them build their
original website but who's actually
built that business that does the
paychecks or enables remote work and
some cool way or whatever it seems like
the biggest problem with crypto right
now is that people talk about it at all
right I think like if you started a
start-up and you just said we pay your
employees at the end of the day
magically and it's not you know II
crypto solutions and you need to use
ether and all this stuff it seems like
it's tight it's like talking about
tcp/ip when you're running a web
business right it's just irrelevant
completely agree and so one of the
another
that we invested in as a company called
zap and they built this thing called
strike which if let's say I want to send
you money if I want to send it through
venmo for example what really is
happening is I'm taking dollars out of
my bank account putting it into my venmo
account sending it to you and then if
you want to you know withdraw that you
can pay a fee and do it immediately or
you can do it for free over like a three
day period or whatever it is what they
allow you to do is send dollars between
two parties cheaper and faster than visa
been mugs that's R what they're actually
technically doing is they're taking
dollars out of my bank account they're
converting it to Bitcoin sending it
across the Lightning Network converting
it back to dollars and handing you the
dollars and so you can imagine you know
on day one they're in every country in
the world because they're just reliant
on the Bitcoin rails things like that
the reason why it's interesting to us is
because you and I never even have to
know anything about Bitcoin right it's
like it's almost being used as like a
payment rail we're just thinking of
dollars I sent you 20 bucks you received
20 bucks and so things like that I agree
with you are where like you're gonna get
the big consumer adoption because
ultimately you know there's a lot of
technology that we use even with money
right I joke all the time and say what
is the car that you carry around most
people they couldn't even tell you the
technology that's there right how do you
use the ATMs how do you send wires and
all this stuff and as you get younger
and younger my whistle story asked my 22
year old brother at the time I said how
do you send money to your friends
they said I use two tools they use venmo
and uber and I remember being like what
do you mean
uber and he's like oh like when we take
a ride together like we split it anew
BRR and I was like how many people over
the age of 30 would think of uber as a
way to send money to people like nobody
right so it's just like these kids are
growing up with you know a phone in
their hand their relationship to kind of
the digital financial world is very
different and so I think that you've got
to definitely break away from the like
hardcore crypto ethos of kind of the
marketing aspect I don't think it to
give up the ethos but you definitely
have to present the information in a way
that is kind of less friction for the
user it's crazy when you think about
just the two and a half percent of every
trans out
it's just gone right sirs rent-seeking
by visa and interchange and stripe and
all those other people that is
staggering and I think there's probably
a lot of lost productivity because of
that two and a half percent like I can't
believe they've been able to hold that
up for fifty years or whatever the one
night that really got me thrown for a
loop was uh
I think was Kroger maybe like a year and
a half ago or so they came out and they
were like look we're not taking and they
just listed a bunch of cards at certain
locations right and I remember customer
backlash being like what do you mean you
know I'm making it up my MasterCard
doesn't work there anymore right and
they were like well let us explain we're
paying you know two point three percent
on every single swipe like no right and
we think you're still going to come to
Kroger you'll just use this other
payment method and so like that's an
egregious response I think from any of
the dollar corporations historically but
I agree with you that once a solution
comes up that says hey I can take that
away right I can take back charge backs
like they might kind of remove all of
this for you people will flock to it the
question is just you know who's gonna
build that solution listen I think I
think also like I was quite excited to
see Facebook do Libre and it's too bad
you know they've had all the regulatory
roadblocks and maybe they're not the
right party to do it or whatever but if
you could go and you could buy something
in Shopify or Instagram and it said pay
with Visa
you know it's two-and-a-half percent
more expensive or save you know ten
bucks and do it using Libre
I think it's profound I think nobody
thinks about that frictional cost that
they're constantly paying and it's just
it's crazy to me yeah and I think this
is the kind of Jack Dorsey at Twitter's
whole focus right with square all this
stuff is his belief is basically the
Internet is a very unique economy
resident kind of think of it as each
country has their own economy then you
have this digital economy built on top
the kind of layers across all of these
boundaries and that economy has very
specific advantages but the money we use
in that economy is still tied to the
physical world and has a lot of friction
to it so he believes right I think as
many people in the Bitcoin community
like Bitcoin will be the native currency
of the internet is it Bitcoin is it
something else everyone will debate
but to me this idea of one square can
now go into any country in the world and
immediately set up shop and not have to
worry about you know FX and all that
kind of stuff that's interesting but to
is you know going back to the strike
example if I can send money to somebody
in the United States whether there's an
individual or merchant and it costs the
same and takes just as long as it
doesn't since that same money to
somebody in China I mean you start
getting into this game of like you're
actually reducing friction drastically
incentivizing commerce on a global scale
and the generation of people on the
internet are going to benefit right I
mean it just changes the economics of a
lot of businesses totally that's cool
so alright man listen I appreciate you
doing this this is awesome I think
people want those flying where can um
where can we send people if they want to
learn more about you tiny or any of the
companies the best thing to do is
probably follow me on Twitter it's a
Wilkinson and our websites tiny capital
comm and they can see the businesses and
stuff there if they want to sauce
business send us an email